chez bibou quand ils envoient des boîtes
à la presse ils se foutent pas de votre
gueule regardez moi ce truc là on se
parle aujourd'hui du nouveau vivo
X Pro un smartphone qui était à la base
de boîte là et qui aujourd'hui est sorti
de sa botte et dans ma main depuis
quelques temps alors je vais vous dire
il y a plein de choses à raconter autour
de ce smartphone on va partager la vidéo
en combien de points j'ai noté en 6
points différents le premier point on va
parler des points positifs à venir
connaitre c'est un smartphone
intéressant on est dans le très haut de
gamme sur une marque qui est pas très
connue aujourd'hui en France même si
elle est partenaire de certains
événements sportifs elle reste quand
même une des grandes inconnues bien
qu'elle soit énorme du côté de la Chine
le deuxième point c'est une autonomie
qui est quand même
assembler il y a plein de choses à venir
soulever également le troisième point
c'est des technologies en moins des
choses qu'on avait avant et qu'on a plus
vous allez voir c'est aussi surprenant
4e point on reste dans la surprise avec
des choix au niveau de la photo qui sont
extrêmement surprenants et vous le voyez
sur le packaging on nous montre de la
photo donc ce sont les optiques et ça
fait référence au bloc photo que vous
avez ici je vais tout vous expliquer
vous allez voir il y a des choses très
surprenantes dans le positif bien
évidemment mais également dans le
négatif cinquième point on va essayer de
comprendre pour qui est fait ce
smartphone à qui il s'adresse est-ce
qu'il est fait pour vous peut-être
d'ailleurs ça on le saura plutôt vers la
fin de la vidéo sixième point c'est
faut-il l'acheter bien évidemment je
donnerai le tarif à ce moment-là et si
ce smartphone vous intéresse et si vous
voulez craquer je vous mets un lien dans
la description c'est un lien
d'affiliation est-ce que vous êtes pris
on va faire le tour aujourd'hui du vivo
X90 Pro tout en sachant qu'il y a une
version plus vivo x 90 pro plus qui est
disponible uniquement en Chine que je ne
vous recommande pas de venir acheter
même si vous pouvez l'importer juste
pour des questions de SAV ça pourrait
être un petit peu relou donc ce
smartphone là et là et aujourd'hui bien
dans mes mains j'ai fait des tonnes de
photos j'ai tout vu avec vous êtes prêt
allez on y va
alors je vous fais un petit retour très
rapidement sur cette boîte pour
comprendre un petit peu de quoi on parle
et bien vivo c'est quand même marré ils
nous ont mis toutes ces trucs là ces
trucs là c'est quoi et bien c'est comme
on est sur un partenariat ici avec zice
zice qui est un spécialiste on va parler
d'optique photo ici donc on vient nous
montrer des parties optiques pour venir
illustrer ça avec cette jolie petite
boule que je peux venir faire rouler
dans ma main si je veux pas tout faire
péter je vais tout péter donc j'arrête
et bien évidemment la boîte du
smartphone qui est juste ici dont on va
passer très très rapidement dessus parce
que globalement il y a pas pas grand
chose à venir raconter même si elle est
très jolie alors on se concentre sur ce
smartphone alors le premier point c'est
les points positifs à connaître ce
smartphone a énormément de points
positifs bien évidemment sans doutera à
commencer par son design alors le truc
qui est intéressant ici c'est que vous
voyez on peut faire très facilement le
tour avec sa main il y a plein de
smartphone qui sont énormes on vient
galérer alors pour autant ça c'est ma
faute qui est quand même relativement
grand j'en veux pour preuve ce grand
écran de 6,78 pouces qu'on va venir donc
utiliser à demain pour arriver sur le
haut néanmoins en termes de tenue de
prise en main à une main c'est très très
bien il y a absolument aucun problème
donc il est vraiment plus dans la
longueur que dans la largeur ça c'est un
truc intéressant à venir connaître
également au niveau du poids on est à
214 g relativement dans la moyenne haute
mais rien de bien déconnant ici vivo a
fait le choix d'un cuir vegan que vous
allez venir retrouver ici alors cuir
vegan c'est vraiment la mode d'utiliser
vegan pour du cuir ce sont vraiment deux
mots qui viennent s'opposer donc il peut
pas y avoir de cuir vegan c'est soit du
cuir et il est pas vegan soit il est
végan et c'est pas du cuir autant vous
dire qu'ici c'est ni du cuir ni vegan
c'est du plastique avec une impression
et un effet touché au niveau du doigt
donne une sensation de cuire mais on est
sur un toucher plastique mais ici n'est
pas le seul à faire vous pouvez l'avez
fait avec Sonic 3 pro il y a plein de
marques qui le font bon bref donc rien
ne surprenant ici on retrouve avec
Motorola également avec son S40 pro donc
bon cuir vegan si vous aimez le toucher
cuir mais que vous voulez agir pour la
planète pourquoi pas du cuir vegan dans
sa chambre ça reste quand même du
plastique entre très gros point positif
à venir connaitre ici c'est la
performance est une belle de performance
smartphone j'en veux pour résultat ce
qu'on va pouvoir trouver sur en toutou
on a un score énorme de 1 million 27
975 et si vous regardez au niveau du
classement vous arrivez en 5e position
juste après le Galaxy S23 ultra qui
tourne avec un stade dragon il n'y a pas
de version avec Xeno cette année on va
retrouver il court ça c'est également la
même boîte que vivo donc en troisième
position le vivo X90 pro plus en
deuxième position et après en premier
c'est le Red Magic 8 Pro plus on va pas
forcément retrouver non plus ici qui est
plus destiné je pense à l'Asie même si
on peut venir l'acheter voilà donc il
est très très bien positionné un
smartphone très performant et d'ailleurs
ils ont fait un choix qui est super
intéressant vivo ici c'est que autant
l'année dernière avec le X80 pro et bien
ils étaient chez Qualcomm avec le
sadragon 8 gène 1 là on se retrouve chez
médiathèque avec
9200 5G qui est un processeur qui tourne
super bien et vous le voyez ici juste au
niveau des benchmark donc c'est une
petite bombe et une fois de plus si vous
intéressez aux questions des fabricants
de puces électroniques et bien on voit
que médiathèque monte vraiment en gamme
et là arrive vraiment au niveau de quoi
comme concrètement sur cette puce très
haut de gamme alors ils ont également
mis le paquet avec 12 Go de RAM c'est un
X dernière techno ça tartine un max et
256 Go de stockage en ufs 4.0 tant vous
dire qu'ici vous avez vraiment un combo
qui fonctionne parfaitement bien tout en
sachant que et comme vous le voyez ici
on travaille vraiment sur l'optique et
sur la photo et bien on a une puce
maison vivo c'est la V2 qui est
complètement dédiée à la photographie
bon la partie photographique on en parle
un peu plus tard tout en sachant qu'en
plus d'un point de vue logiciel vous
pouvez venir augmenter votre âme vous
avez déjà 12 giga de ram et bien
regardez vous venez ici vous pouvez lui
rajouter 8 gigas de RAM ce qui vous fait
un 20 giga de ram global autant vous
dire qu'ici ça va venir tartiner un axe
en plus de ça vous allez avoir un
refroidissement grâce à la chambre à
vapeur lors de grosses sessions gaming
donc pas de problème de chauffe ici un
très gros point positif à connaître et
bien je voulais montrer tout à l'heure
cette grande écran de 6,78 pouces taux
de rafraîchissement de 100 mètres
extrêmement lumineux il va monter
jusqu'à 1310 regardez hop ça c'est très
très lumineux alors je vais éviter de
vous mettre à fond pour la vidéo sans
quoi ça risque un peu de vous arracher
les yeux Full HD plus c'est de la
molette certifié HDR Nice plus qui va
également bien prendre soin de vos yeux
donc ça c'est aussi très très bien autre
truc et très positif et vous le voyez
ici c'est toute la partie logiciel ça
fonctionne très bien paramétrable
personnalisable très efficace du côté de
chez vivo ici donc pas de souci c'est
fun touch basé sur Android 13 autre
point positif ici vous avez votre bloc
de charge qui est inclus
qui est bien de de plus en plus rare
pour venir souligner et on se parle ici
de charge rapide 120 watts autant vous
dire que votre smartphone il va être
chargé assez rapidement puisque je vous
parle de charge et vous parlais
d'autonomie c'est notre deuxième point
c'est une autonomie qui intrigante la
batterie de votre smartphone elle
contient deux cellules de cellules qui
vont venir se recharger en même temps
pratique on les en totale du 4870
milliampères heure grosse batterie on
pourrait se dire ici donc grosse
autonomie pour autant l'autonomie c'est
pas son point fort on va venir tenir en
fonction des usages sur l'usage moyen
une grosse journée une bonne journée on
arrive pas sur les un jour et demi voire
deux jours de certains smartphones alors
ça c'est truc qui est un peu relou parce
que quand on achète un smartphone comme
ça un peu plus de 1000 balles parce que
c'est un smartphone coûte un peu plus de
1000 euros on voudrait une belle
autonomie on va pas l'avoir
nécessairement ici alors après le truc
qui peut être un petit peu rassurant
c'est que je vous l'ai dit et bien dans
votre boîte vous avez effectivement un
bloc de charge de 120 watts qui inclut
donc la question du manque d'autonomie
va pas être très importante parce que
vous allez pouvoir venir le recharger
rapidement le truc qui est un peu relou
c'est qu'il faut tout le temps avoir
votre bug de charge dans ma boîte pour
le recharger rapidement ou sinon si vous
avez un chargeur sans fil 50 watts qui
traîne pas loin et bien vous le
rechargerez également rapidement moins
rapidement qu'en semble à Watt mais
quand même en
d'autres usages à savoir que sur le X80
pro et bien vous avez votre zone de
capteur d'empreintes digitale et au
dessus vous avez des petites icônes des
petits raccourcis par exemple vous
posiez votre doigt au dessus sur l'icône
de YouTube vous arriviez vous
déverrouillez directement en arrivant
sur Youtube vous pouvez donc vous dire
personnaliser totalement l'application
sur laquelle vous allez arriver
l'application message l'application
Téléphone bref c'était extrêmement
pratique tout ça grâce à ce grand
emplacement au niveau du capteur
d'empreintes digitale et là on est sur
la génération suivante X90 pro modèle
très haut de gamme et bien ça on ne le
retrouve plus donc ça je trouve ça un
peu dommage autre chose qui a disparu et
bien c'est le taux de rafraîchissement
variable alors là pour autant vous avez
un écran avec un taux de
rafraîchissement qui va jusqu'à 120
Hertz ça c'est très bien sauf que ici
vous n'avez pas de dalle ltpo qui vous
permet d'aller de 1 à 120 Hertz
automatiquement non votre smartphone va
donc venir switcher soit intelligemment
entre du 60-90 120 Hertz soit vous le
poussez directement en 60 pour venir
économiser un peu au niveau de la
batterie soit vous le poussez on s'en va
sans permanence vous allez venir
consommer davantage et sur ce smartphone
là qui a pas les meilleurs autonomie ça
sera un petit peu dommage alors vous le
laissez en bascule intelligente job sera
fait attention mais une fois plus comme
on est sur un smartphone très haut de
gamme à plus de 1000 euros on
s'attendrait à retrouver technologique
qu'on avait sur un modèle antérieur sur
ce modèle là et c'est pas le cas autre
point qui était super intéressant vous
allez voir c'est encore un peu différent
vivo a vraiment fait le focus sur un de
ces derniers modèles sur le fait d'avoir
une caméra gimball avec une
stabilisation sur 5 axes notamment sur X
Y Z bon je sais pas ce truc un petit peu
là-dessus donc cette caméra gimbo là
elle est cool sauf que aujourd'hui et
bien vivo ne nous parle plus de caméra
gimball alors pour autant ils ont un
truc qui fonctionne toujours très bien
lorsque vous êtes dans votre application
photo et que vous venez dans vidéo ce
que le Game ball c'est plus pour la
vidéo on s'en doutera et bien vous venez
ici juste en haut niveau de la stab vous
avez le stabilisation standard ultra et
vous avez surtout la ligne horizontale
ce qui permet effectivement et bien
voyez je lance l'enregistrement je suis
comme ça je viens tourner ma tête tourne
alors que normalement sur n'importe quel
smartphone elle resterait droite donc
voyez je suis toujours au centre et
lorsque vous venez mettre lecture et que
vous regardez votre vidéo et bien c'est
là que c'est extrêmement bluffant vous
voyez ça a tourné et bien je mets voilà
face à moi là je suis en train de
tourner le smartphone je tourne le
smartphone je tourne le smartphone là je
l'ai complètement à l'envers et l'image
ne tourne pas donc pour autant ici je
n'entends plus parler je ne vois plus
parler de caméra gimball est-elle
toujours intégrée est-ce uniquement du
logiciel c'est complètement possible en
tout cas cette fonctionnalité est
toujours là en 1080p à 30 images par
seconde donc si vous attendiez à bien
filmer ici en 4k avec ce système là
c'est pas possible ici vivo ne parle
plus de caméra gimball j'ai donc
l'impression que le gimbo n'est plus là
même si on retrouve quand même des
fonctionnalités qui sont héritées tout
ça alors le dernier point c'est pas une
techno en moins c'est une techno qu'on a
pas et qui me fait râler on a bien
évidemment du wifi 6 sur ce smartphone
pour bien se connecter rapidement avec
votre box mais pas forcément avec les
box de dernière génération qui sont en
wifi 6e tout en sachant qu'il y a pas
mal de smartphone dans le très haut de
gamme qui commence à arriver avec du
wifi 7 ici vous avez du wifi 6 c'est
bien c'est rapide attention mais pas de
wifi 6e et on ne parle toujours pas de
wifi 7 en tout cas pour l'instant le
quatrième point et bien ce sont des
choix un peu surprenants au niveau de la
partie photo alors je vous explique en
fait vous le voyez et on le voyez déjà
ici il vous le mettez vous avez pas en
fait quatre capteurs vous avez en
réalité trois capteurs votre capteur
principal votre grand angle qui est là
c'est un 50 mégapixels et surtout un
capteur de 1 pouce donc le 1 pouce on
l'a pas sur tous les smartphones
commence à le voir arriver ça c'est
vachement bien parce que pour les photos
avec plus de détails et notamment
conditions de faible luminosité c'est
juste vachement bien vous avez ici un
ultra grand-angle de 12 mégapixels c'est
parfait c'est rat très très bien ok on
va regarder les photos dans quelques
instants et ça c'est surprenant pourquoi
parce que vous avez une caméra portrait
de 50 mégapixels alors je me dis ok ça
c'est chouette mais en fait aujourd'hui
dans le tripty classique ce qu'on
s'attend dans le très haut de gamme
c'est avoir grand angle on l'a ultra
grand-angle on l'a tué l'objectif on l'a
pas alors attention attention c'est pas
complètement vrai ici vivant est venu
mettre une caméra portrait et qui va
dans 50 mm ça veut dire que vous avez un
zoom optique x 2 mais qui est là
vraiment dédié pour le mode portrait pas
tant pour venir zoomer et lorsque vous
allez dans le logiciel de photos et bien
c'est pareil vous avez x grand angle
ultra grand-angle x 0,6 et vous avez le
X 2 qui en fait est en X 2 numérique qui
ne va pas utiliser le téléobjectif
portrait je vous montre comment ça
fonctionne vous voyez par exemple là hop
je suis en foin je vous ai dit que ma
caméra portrait c'était celle-là donc je
vais venir poser mon doigt dessus et
lorsque je passe en X 2 et bien voyez
donc là je suis en X 2 j'ai bien mon
doigt sur le portrait je passe en
dessous sur la caméra principale donc là
je suis sur la caméra principale et je
remonte au dessus sur le portrait et ce
qui est très intéressant c'est que si je
viens zoomer je pose mon doigt je zoome
je zoome je zoom je zoom je zoom je zoom
et bien vous allez voir que jusqu'en x
10 enfin x 9,9 et bien je suis sur la
caméra principale le capteur de 50
mégapixel avec le capteur de 1 pouce et
lorsque j'arrive au foie 10 et bien là
je switch sur le portrait et là
effectivement c'est plus très
intéressant faut 10 parce que en fait je
suis sur un X 2 optique sur cette caméra
de portrait donc c'est tout du zoom
numérique donc en fait ce qui se passe
c'est que dès que vous allez commencer à
venir zoomer sur ce smartphone même sur
du X 2 vous êtes sur un zoom numérique
vous n'avez pas de zoom optique puisque
sur la plage x 2 à x 9,9 vous êtes sur
un zoom numérique sur le capteur
principal de 50 mégapixels donc on vient
rogner dans le capteur et dès que vous
arrivez au X vous êtes déjà sur un zoom
numérique sur un équivalent 50
mégapixels donc en fait ici vous n'avez
pas de zoom optique ah aucun moment et
ça c'est relativement con et vous allez
voir que le résultat c'était vraiment
sentir là-dessus bon et par contre vous
avez une caméra de selfie ici de 32
mégapixels alors ce sont des choix qui
sont un peu surprenant après il y a
vraiment un truc très positif ici au
niveau de la photo c'est que comme vous
êtes sur un parten le cas avec Zeiss
voyez c'est écrit ici en blanc en bleu
sur noir cuir vegan pas réellement vegan
semble l'avait compris et bien vous avez
des optiques zice Esaï c'est
mondialement connu pour la qualité de
ses optiques donc ça c'est aussi un très
gros point fort on voit qu'aujourd'hui
les marques sur le haut de gamme
viennent vraiment chercher des
partenariats forts on le voit avec
Xiaomi Laïka ici ces ice ça apportera
donc un côté anti-reflet ça évitera des
halo parasites bref il y a plein
d'avantages à venir travailler avec un
spécialiste ici au niveau de la petite
je vous ai fait des tonnes de photos
lorsque j'étais à austino Texas que
j'étais à Paris j'étais au sud de
Lisbonne bref je vous ai fait plein de
photos je vais vous montrer très
rapidement je trouve que dans l'ensemble
c'est un très très bon photophone soyons
clair ici même si il y a des choix un
peu bizarres qui ont été arbitrés ici
alors bon au niveau de la nourriture ça
fonctionne c'est beau ça donne enfin ça
c'est cool je vous montre quelques
petites photos à Austin en plein jour ça
marche le grand angle est très bon ultra
grand-angle et très bon il y a surtout
une vraie cohérence au niveau de la
colorimétrie je trouve ça bien un peu
moins de piquer sur l'ultra grand temps
que sur le grand angle mais rien de bien
déconnant ici puis après on peut bien
sonner mais vous avez compris qu'en fait
on en zoomer on est sur du numérique et
c'est pas foufou et vous allez le voir
alors là je vous montre quelques petites
photos je défie assez rapidement
regardez là pas beau au niveau du détail
que ce que vous avez sur le verre ça
extrêmement efficace là le mode portrait
j'ai pris mon pote Michael en photo
coucou Michael et bien je trouve que le
mode portrait est très joli très doux
avec un feu arrière-plan qui est très
bien maîtrisé sans le verra plus tard
une fois de plus et tout l'intérêt
d'avoir mis 50 mm portrait ici vous
voyez je trouve un truc qui est assez
joli alors là je prends la photo dans un
miroir mais je trouve que c'est assez
sympa et ça fonctionne bien là j'ai fait
différents modes portraits vous voyez
alors bon des fois il galérait un peu
mais je trouve qu'il y a des trucs qui
sont très jolis aussi au niveau de la
colorimétrie regardez là c'est assez
sympa alors après si on a envie de
s'amuser on peut sortir des trucs assez
rigolo comme ici dans des toilettes donc
dans l'ensemble au niveau des couleurs
elles sont très bien restituées là
gestion des Lumières est très très bonne
ici lorsque vous avez pas de lumière et
lorsque vous avez la lumière et que vous
êtes en extérieur là je vous montre sur
un concert et là déjà je trouve que vous
voyez là j'ai un peu de bruit sur mon
image là c'est pas terrible et lorsque
je viens me rapprocher vous voyez là on
perd vraiment tous les détails au niveau
des visages c'est pas terrible en fait
et c'est vraiment même si on a 50 mm il
nous manque vraiment un téléobjectif
pour sortir des photos de qualité
lorsqu'on veut venir zoomer dans l'image
et ça ça ne manque mais plus plus plus
regardez ça regardez ça c'est pas beau
quoi et ça c'est vraiment la limite
qu'on va venir retrouver avec des choix
très surprenants au niveau de la photo
regardez même là là ça me fait des
choses qui sont assez bizarres et qui
pour moi ne fonctionne pas alors je vous
montre plein d'autres photos que je suis
venu faire à Austin grand angle ultra
grand-angle c'est plutôt bien ça
fonctionne bien bon au lieu de 31 zoomer
ça je voulais déjà montré mais dans
l'ensemble ça marche la caméra de selfie
est pas mauvaise aussi je trouve
regardez là c'est pareil en selfie ça
fonctionne regardez ça me fait marrer
voilà c'est ridicule mais ça me fait
rire bonjour je sais pas pourquoi ça me
fait absolument rien cette photo le mode
portrait la voyait très doux alors là il
a un petit peu de mal au niveau des
petits cheveux quand on est retrouvé
juste au-dessus là mais sinon
globalement le job est fait alors en
condition de faible luminosité dans une
soirée alors vous allez voir que la nuit
va commencer à tomber et bien il s'en
sort quand même plutôt pas mal là on a
aussi un mode portrait je trouve ça très
joli il est vraiment très très douce
mode portrait donc il y a vraiment un
côté très positif ici et en condition de
faible luminosité le job est fait voyez
au niveau de la gestion des lumières
c'est tout un peu compliqué des fois et
bah là il le maîtrise bien là c'est
pareil la gestion des Lumières est très
très belle avec ce flou derrière là et
ça qui est net je trouve ça très très
beau et très très doux dans l'ensemble
ce smartphone fait de jolies photos de
très jolies photos même si on va pouvoir
reprocher qu'il est pas parfait là vous
voyez au niveau de l'éclairage Marshall
tout est très très bien maîtrisé là
aussi ça fonctionne bien et c'est joli
vous voyez de cette scène là c'est
vraiment bien fait là au niveau des
photos de nuit dans une ville et bien je
trouve ça pas mal alors là il a eu un
petit peu de mal là mais malgré tout il
y a un côté qui reste assez joli au
niveau de l'éclairage comme on peut
l'avoir ici donc bon ça fonctionne la
caméra de selfie la nuit on oublie les
dégueulasse par contre très clairement
ça marche pas du tout alors ils ont un
espèce de mode qui s'appelle le mode
super lui hein je vous montre le mode
super Lune vous venez l'activer et c'est
censé améliorer les photos de votre lune
de la lune en tout cas pour moi
globalement ça sert vraiment à rien du
tout c'est pas terrible alors ça c'est
un truc qui est assez marrant parce
qu'en fait c'est un mode très fake ou
vous venez photographier le ciel avec la
lune et lui il vous met un espèce de
paysage qui n'existe pas j'étais pas du
tout dans la Sierra Nevada à ce
moment-là vous voyez en fait j'ai juste
la lune qui est venue me la balader
alors je cherchais ma lune pour bien
avoir au bon endroit vous voyez j'essaie
de bien la placer en dessous là là je
n'ai pas mal placé mais globalement
c'est que du fake ces photos n'existent
pas par contre en termes de photos de
nuit voyez alors il faisait très nuit il
faut le savoir donc ça marche quand même
vachement mais ça c'est vraiment une
petite particularité aussi je pense de
zice c'est que vous voyez les lumières
et bien ça vous fait cet effet de halo
qui est très jolie quand on est retrouvé
autour de ses éclairages là et voyez les
photos de nuit elles sont belles le ciel
est bien détaillé ressort bien il y a
une très très très jolie maîtrise même à
contre-jour avec le soleil une tronche
ça marche et après il va me proposer
différentes choses différents effets au
niveau du mode portrait des effets
signés zice qui sont quand même plutôt
pas mal mais bon vous voyez il y a des
trucs un peu comme ça vidéo portrait
film c'est un peu surprenant voilà bon
après c'est un petit P et on peut aller
jusqu'à des choses comme ça bon pourquoi
pas si vous voulez le cinquième point
c'est de savoir pour qui est fait ce
smartphone à qui est-il destiné ce qu'il
est fait pour vous alors soyons clair
c'est un smartphone très haut de gamme
avec quelques choix particuliers si vous
êtes photographe si vous voulez faire de
très belles photos si vous voulez un
smartphone on est partout avec vous pour
venir shooter des choses par exemple
vous voulez faire safari venir shooter
les animaux un petit peu loin pour moi
non c'est smartphone n'est pas du tout
fait pour vous parce qu'il manque ce
téléobjectif et une fois de plus c'est
quand même très dommage ici que vivo
n'est pas mis donc si vous voulez avoir
le téléobjectif il faut aller sur le
vivo X90 pro plus dispo uniquement en
Chine et une fois de plus je ne vous le
recommande pas parce qu'elle est dispo
uniquement en Chine en termes de SAV
s'il y a un problème et de garantie ça
peut être un peu plus complexe donc on
évite mais c'est pour autant vous voulez
un très beau smartphone avec une très
belle expérience soit pour le multimédia
pour le gaming avec un écran qui est
très bien calibré avec de l'audio qui
fonctionne bien qui qui est spatialisé
qui marche bien alors là-dessus vous
n'avez absolument aucun problème le
format est agréable il est très bon film
série divertissement il y a beaucoup de
performances donc si c'est vraiment ce
que vous voulez là il y a pas de
problème attention également à toutes
les personnes qui n'ont pas forcément
accès à une prise pour venir se
recharger régulièrement et bien c'est
pas forcément le smartphone qui vous
faudra à cause de cette autonomie qui
est pas mauvaise mais qui n'est pas non
plus folle folle folle donc c'est un
smartphone qui est à la fois très cool
au niveau de la photo parce qu'il y a
vraiment des particularités grâce
notamment à ses optiques Weiss vous le
voyez au niveau du rendu photographique
il est très bon sur le capteur de 1
pouce mais il est pas aussi polyvalent
qu'on voudrait en tout cas que ce qu'on
viendrait attendre d'un smartphone n'a
plus de 1000 euros ce qui nous emmène au
6e point faut-il venir l'acheter alors
ça c'est compliqué pourquoi parce qu'une
fois de plus vivo c'est une marque qui
est assez peu connue ici qui lorsque
vous arrivez à des tarifs très élevés et
bien on va plus aller faire des marques
qui vont rassurer ici on est sur un
smartphone à 1199 euros c'est beaucoup
d'argent 1199 euros et souvent les gens
se disent ah bah tiens moi si j'ai mis
le bal je vais aller chez Samsung j'ai
entendu plein de gens me dire ça tiens
est-ce que tu connais ce smartphone ah
bah non je le connais pas c'est qui
c'est quoi c'est vivo qui fait ça c'est
cool c'est cool ah il coûte combien il
coûte 1199 € ou là et on me dit à ce
moment-là ah bah si j'ai plus de 1000 €
à mettre à ce moment-là je vais aller
chez Samsung donc on a plus l'idée de se
dire que sur Android on ira dans le
Premium chez Samsung si on a beaucoup
d'argent mais on accepterait plus dans
le milieu de gamme et l'entrée de gamme
d'aller sur des marques on connaîtrait
un petit peu moins on se dit
probablement si on dépense mon argent on
va être moins exigeante sauf qu'en
réalité c'est pas réellement comme ça
qu'il faut venir le prendre en tout cas
c'est ce que je pense qu'on va dans
notre tête est-ce que je comprends bien
évidemment donc faut-il venir l'acheter
une fois de plus ça dépend de vous et de
vos usages si vous voulez un
téléobjectif n'achetez pas le vivo X90
pro si vous voulez un bel écran si vous
voulez surtout faire des photos en mode
portrait si vous êtes fana de votre
portrait et bien je trouve très cool
très jolie et très sympa dans ce sens là
mais une fois de plus l'absence de
téléobjectif ici il est vraiment de
poser un problème donc est-ce qu'il faut
l'acheter je dirais peut-être mais une
fois de plus ça va être plus limitatif
ça va être affirmer plus de portes qu'un
smartphone qui aurait un tel objectif
avec un joli mode portrait qui serait
géré différemment pour autant est-ce que
ce vivo X90 Pro est réussi la réponse et
je pense oui est-ce que il vaut a fait
des choix un peu bizarre je pense que
oui s'ils étaient venus mettre des
techno on avait avant et bien ça
m'aurait moins frustré alors après c'est
peut-être pour venir rationaliser les
coups aujourd'hui c'est plus compliqué
bien évidemment il y a une inflation le
coût de la mettre la première a
forcément augmenté également pour les
fabricants et puis une fois de plus vivo
en France et pas très connu donc on met
pas l'ensemble de sa gamme comme on
pourrait le retrouver en Chine mais le
smartphone qui aurait été vraiment le
plus intéressant à venir vous présenter
peut-être à retrouver sur le marché
français ça aurait été le vivo x 90 pro
plus mais une fois de plus il aurait été
trop cher tout en sachant qu'une marque
comme vivo et bien elle vous présente
des smartphones très haut de gamme elle
sait qu'elle va pas en vendre énormément
mais le fait de vous montrer ces
technologies est-ce qu'elle est capable
de faire et la force d'un partenariat
avec zice et bien c'est plus pour
argumenter et venir vous séduire sur le
milieu et l'entrée de gamme ou là par
contre elle fera globalement son chiffre
d'affaires et elle fera son beurre donc
est-ce que vous allez l'acheter je pense
que vous n'allez pas l'acheter je pense
que si vous avez plus de 1000 euros vous
n'irez pas sur cette marque pour autant
est-ce qu'il est bien oui est-ce qu'il
me frustre oui est-ce que je peux le
recommander pas pour tout le monde mais
ça reste malgré tout un très beau
smartphone et un très très beau travail
il y a des technologies très bien
maîtrisées ici de la part de vivo j'ai
hâte de voir ce qui arriverait l'année
prochaine d'autant plus qu'on arrivait
au bout un peu du naiming X 90 est-ce
que vous croyez qu'il nous feront un X
sans pro l'année prochaine est-ce qu'ils
garderont le sens en 1020 c'est bizarre
allez savoir d'ailleurs dites moi ce que
vous en pensez en bas dans les
commentaires comment est-ce que vous
trouvez ce smartphone est-ce que vous
pourriez aller dessus est-ce qu'il
pourrait vous intéresser vous marquez
tout ça dans les commentaires et nous on
se retrouve très bientôt pour continuer
à parler de plein de smartphone qui
arrivent que j'ai là je ne peux pas
encore vous parler donc je vous parlais
très bientôt et d'ailleurs ce smartphone
vous intéresse n'oubliez pas je vous ai
mis un lien d'affiliation dans la
description je vous embrasse pour les
soin de vous et à très bientôt Ciao
[Musique]